Này 1 sau tháng 2, hẳng thông tấn tán sẵn phát biểu của chú từ cu ba mi gên đi á, kênh trên nền chú biết
học thúc của sự của cu ba hoàn toàn mang tính phòng vệ và thông nhằm vào bất thị của sang nào trong đó có nghĩ
nhà lãnh đào cu ba thành định là ha bà nè không chờ phép đặt tân từ cuốn sử nước ngoài chỉ lãnh thô
Đồng thời chân sang tân từ cuốn sử Mỹ tại của ta nè mò là sự hiện dịnh bắt hử pháp dưới nhất
Chú tình đi á, kênh nhấn mạnh, cu ba sẵn sẽ đối thoại vì Mỹ về mọi phần đây, mối điều kiện không có bình tháp dây xếc
bà phải dự chân hình tháp mình đạo tôn trọng chủ cuyên
cho ông chỉ có đối thoại không được kiện mới có phần xây dựu quan hệ phần mêng giữa các cuốn sà lãnh sìng
cùng ngay cho lời kênh hoa phòng bất li của anh tất cả biểu của chú từ cu ba
như phần thà hẹn chẳng khẳng li của các đàn phán hỏi ra sông thường và nơi lưu xúc tiến
nhưng tựu thành báo xí đẩn phùi đối với cu ba
cho bất cảnh của chính tình xa tăng cơ biển phát triệu pháp
lãnh đậu khu ba cho biến đất này nhận được dựu hộ của nhiều cua ra và đối tác cu tế
để nụ cuối cho biến đăng theo dõi xóa xa xa tình như nhìn đạo tệ cu ba
đã biệt chứ những thứ tinh với năng lợp
đồng thời tức được kêu gọi chấm rất bình pháp cấm vận đơn giân
và thúc đầy đối thoại phù hộp lợp khá cu tế